qu'est-ce qui s'est passé mon bébé de
couple qu'est-ce qui s'est passé les
bêtises dis-moi qu'est-ce que tu penses
non en fait ce qui se passe je raconte
pour de vrai hier j'annonce à mon
camarade avec Thionville je dis voilà
j'ai pris une décision je pense que un
soir par semaine je vais te bouffer le
cul non
il va être fou de colère que je raconte
ça
vaut mieux que tu gardes ton job et que
tu perds ton mec
je te crois pas je dis je lui dis on
habite ensemble mais il a un appartement
pas mal à côté tu dis ça serait bien je
pense que on est un jour par semaine
peut-être le mercredi ou ce soir-là
chacun est chez soi tu vois pas mal
non c'est trop beau
et je le dis pour les coups si tu peux
écoute si tu peux c'est
trois jours avec sa meuf quatre jours
sans vous l'avez déjà expérimenté
[Rires]
et 1h au téléphone et ça marche très
bien voilà ça se passe très bien alors
donc qu'est-ce qui te dit là-dessus donc
je dis un jour c'est quand même
c'est chez soi
merci
et il me dit qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette histoire un jour un couple
s'habille tout le temps ensemble ça sort
d'où les stades de Monsieur
mais tu sais pourquoi tu vas parce qu'il
me dit on pourrait ne pas avoir de jours
fixe et tentant tu es fatigué tu me dis
non bien sûr mais il me dit je pense que
tu veux un jour fixe pour aller voilà
voilà voilà pour pouvoir caler peut-être
des des rencontres et tu sais ce jour-là
je ne serai pas là exactement
et tu me comprends bien sûr que je te
c'est horrible c'est horrible horrible
donc il me dit tu veux commencer quand
bah là tu lui as dit ce soir exactement
du coup ça part sur est-ce que tu me
trompes non oh le [ __ ]
le [ __ ] le jugement
il faut le comprendre
s'il te plaît ne rajoute pas toujours
que jusqu'à ça dure quand même est-ce
que tu me trompes est-ce que c'est pour
ça que tu veux qu'elle est le mercredi
c'est horrible moi en bonne Hanouna
qu'est-ce que je dis c'est pas répondre
à ces questions tu vois je sais pas ah
tu ne me fais pas confiance
ah tu ne me fais pas confiance tu ne me
fais pas confiance je peux te répondre
mais je te préviens
si je réponds si je réponds derrière
c'est
fini
c'est pas ça bon il m'a dit réponds-moi
une news
quoi comment ça quoi
comme toi
il y a longtemps
parce que j'ai remarqué que c'est comme
dans les hôtels et les restaurants si tu
dis Anouna dit ça te ça t'assie la
phrase
oui j'ai dit de façon déjà c'est
ridicule ce que tu dis comme dit Cyril
on tombe amoureux de l'amour
c'est moi qui ai dit cette connerie
[Rires]
mais on n'est pas dans TPMP ici
le TPMP te plaît bien quand on a un
weekend à Versailles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
excusez-moi
je me levais
juste votre avis pour le coup est-ce que
vraiment tu as raison demander une
journée par semaine
arrête un peu tu sais
c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on se repose PlayStation on est là on
regarde un petit film qui me plaît tu
vois franchement
une bulle on peut pas comme ça
moi j'adore Fast and Furious lui il est
moins masculin que moi tu vois c'est la
merde ces conneries
on a le droit d'être égoïste une journée
par semaine
et je veux dire ce que je pense tu as
déjà été trop gentil une journée tu
aurais dû dire trois quatre jours je te
le dis ouais
en plus un studio
il a peur que toi c'est possible tu
puisses partir alors que lui il a pas
d'opportunité c'est pas la théorie de ma
sœur elle me dit c'est qu'en fait tu le
rassures pas ah c'est ça et donc
animateur tu as du succès tes beaux
gosses ta nanana
moi je suis pas gay mais je supporte pas
que mon petit ami dans le sang noir
juste on demande de ne pas mentir
s'il te plaît non mais c'est vrai voilà
on est on est pas là on n'est pas là
pour mentir
c'est pas parce que moi je me rappelle
j'avais une meuf
tu as une meuf toi
bah oui
bien sûr
84 2 semaines avant Pedro ah d'accord
d'accord j'allais acheter le pain elle
croyait que j'allais Ken la boulangerie
mais non mais c'est bien quand je confie
comme ça
entre potes tu vois alors toi toi qui a
fait ton coming out il y a pas longtemps
que j'arrive moi
[Rires]
je trouve c'est vrai que le jour ça moi
si on me l'avait fait ça m'aurait
dérangé si toi et tu avais dit j'ai
besoin de plus te voir le mardi j'aurais
pris comment le jour fixe me dérange le
jour ça il est gay femme ok waouh c'est
un concept ça bah oui parce que
exactement tu penses comme une femme
c'est un enfer mais lui c'est pareil tu
vois un dimanche il m'a même des fleurs
non je te jure oh là là
[Applaudissements]
j'ai jamais le droit à un mot d'amour
[Musique]
[Rires]
et je le dis aux gens qui n'ont pas les
moyens évidemment je ne comprends
habiter ensemble ceux qui ont les moyens
et ben profiter de la vie chacun de son
côté on se retrouve
la vérité moi je préfère dormir dans la
rue seul de soi que dormir avec ma meuf
tous les soirs je vais demander de
dormir dans la rue là mais toi tu as
qu'à y aller ah bah c'est chez moi quand
même
soit altruiste
dans la rue avec d'autres personnes ou
avec ton mec dans la dans mon appart
c'est pas faux mais il y a aussi des
dégâts chez ton dans ton appart
mais là tu vois bien que c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible je suis
content que si il écoute parce que tout
le monde pensait il fait la fameuse
phrase de mais tous les gens disent que
mais tout le monde fait ça il y a que
toi il y a que moi tu veux que je te dis
ce que je pense il se foutent de ta
gueule
et ouvre les yeux parce que regarde
Castaldi il a laissé les yeux fermés
pendant des années
aujourd'hui mais reste en dehors de tout
ça
s'il te plaît
parce que parce que tu regardes comme un
alors dis pas le prénom c'est un fou
dans la merde sa mère et tout mais juste
voilà le mercredi juste chacun de son
côté
ça te paraît totalement naturel
Jean-Charles
appelle Lonté
[Rires]
dans le milieu si tu nous regardes
que
c'est un nom de code Mathieu a besoin de
liberté et si tu veux que ton couple
dure si tu veux lâche un jour pour
gagner des années ça c'est deux jours
pour gagner une vie
[Musique]
vaut mieux lâcher deux jours
que de gâcher votre relation merci
Mathieu il a besoin de deux jours mais
tu as raison 3 jours
pour les ternités
[Musique]
et Mathieu sera avec toi pendant
longtemps très longtemps à mon matou de
l'amour bien sûr
[Musique]
sache que si tu fais ça j'ai pas pour
aller batifolie bah non c'est juste pour
essayer de se retrouver voilà
papa bien sûr
tu n'as pas bien sûr des vility
là on est bien là c'était bien c'était
bien c'était bien